[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler
review of ozark season four part two i'm
gonna be talking about every single
episode of this season's second half so
make sure you watch all of it before you
watch this review there's gonna be some
heavy spoilers here and it's my first
review of ozark i'm excited to talk
about it it's one of the most requested
shows i've ever had for me to cover and
i have a lot of mixed feelings about
this part too so let's jump right into
it so we'll start with season four
episode eight the cousin of death this
was directed by amanda marsalis and
written by showrunner chris mundy now
this was like the episode for ruth right
that was the nas episode instead of
biggie now she's in nas mode she's
playing some great songs but him like
new york state of mind one of my
favorites and what i loved about this
first episode of part two is that they
dealt with the javi story with her right
away you know they could have dragged
that out the whole second half here and
that would have really slowed things
down but i like they addressed it
immediately especially because in the
trailer for this part two is that they
showed her shoot hobby so you're kind of
like is that just gonna happen but they
show it obviously it was a dream
sequence and i thought those two fake
out kills of her thinking of shooting
javi and then shooting the birds worked
because it paid off in that final moment
of this episode for ruth and getting
inside of her mindset and how she felt
about javi obviously but also the birds
and i love this episode because she
finally says her truth to wendy and
marty and it's a very jesse pinkman
moment to walter white that's really
what her character kind of represents to
me in this show it's the one we kind of
root for the most in love and everything
she does is more out of a just mindset
than the selfishness we see in the birds
and i love her calling wendy's soulless
and saying that marty's basically her
puppy dog but in a more cursive way did
anyone else here want her to just shoot
wendy through that window i don't know
if it's just me but man is wendy so
hateable i i don't remember such a
hateable character in a while for me i
know everyone's got a lot of different
thoughts about wendy and she's
polarizing and i really do like laura
linney's portrayal and that's session
about betrayal she's so you know
polarizing as a character but i'm in
that boat that i cannot stand the
character of wendy and there's a lot
here with julia garner who's really the
scene stealer of the show ruth she's
taken over the show that's where i am at
with the show i was most invested in her
character and that's to the end and just
little things comedically like her
impression of charlotte in this episode
really stood out to me that was great
now was i crazy with the killer mic
cameo not really you know that's where
ozark kind of makes itself a little
corny compared to other shows like it
but i get it because they used run the
jewels song to end last season so
happy wasn't like so integral to the
story but again just wasn't totally
needed but this actually was my favorite
episode of part two i thought from top
to bottom it was such a like rush i mean
ozark's best is when it's the most
suspenseful it's one of the most
suspenseful shows i've ever made and
this episode does all its strengths
right and really being with ruth most of
the time and through her perspective is
where it shines and it shows you like
again how good of a character ruth is
and it's going to go to my problems with
how they end this show which you're
going to get to but showing you how
great it is just spending time with ruth
makes me really mad about something
which i want to address at the end but
we'll get to that so episode 9 here is
called pick a god and pray again
directed by amanda marsalis but this
time written by laura dealey now i like
the opening scene here with wendy and
marty they have a time to kind of catch
air in the season at this point and talk
about how they feel about each other and
marty's showing his care for ruth here
and he's like she's lost everyone
because of us and wendy turns on marty
and blames him for getting them into
this and you know it's true there's
truth to that that this story really is
marty getting the family into that but
making the monster that is now wendy now
where i got frustrated if we look at
this season as a whole is that we see
the care of marty's always had for ruth
and i think the core relationship that's
the best relationship in the show is
ruth and marty's i keep doing these
breaking bad references but there's so
many similarities and it reminds me of
that walter white jesse pinkman
relationship where it's like he loves
jesse pinkman like a son walter white
and that i felt was marty to ruth almost
more than his own kids but what
frustrates me is seeing his care for
ruth even in the scene to wendy and that
when we get to the finale that i was
supposed to believe that marty was gonna
let ruth just die even though it
threatened his own kids i do think marty
would have done something different and
i'm gonna get more into the finale but
it's gonna bring to my frustration about
how they ended this whole thing but in
episode 9 again really good pace a lot
of moving pieces here which i liked it
was like a chess game between navarro
and camila and wendy and ruth and marty
and it was really so entertaining wendy
having this big win here in this episode
where you know she stands up and isn't
scared by navarro when he's basically
screaming at her that's going to kill
her and that she takes a bold move and
takes him out of solidarity and it works
and they bring in this piece now of the
grandpa back and he hired mel the pi to
look into ben so so much going on to
build suspense with the show is at its
best as suspense that's what it's best
at and it's good that it's going back to
the bend story bringing things full
circle which i like seeing now one of
the plot holes i'm not crazy about is
how obsessed wendy was for a whole
season getting zeke back the baby and
has no care for zeke this whole season
like especially after darlene dies you
would think that she'd be trying to get
zeke back they just dropped that
completely with her so that was not
believable to me but this was a great
episode as a stellar even come down from
episode one so i'm giving this one a 9.2
now episode 10 titled you're the boss
was also one of my favorites it was
directed by melissa hickey written by
john schieben and it's cool because it's
got the story i did really enjoy with
marty going to mexico now now he has to
be the boss here right and he's taking
the role of navarro and i like that when
he's torturing someone that he doesn't
trust he's using the heavy metal thing
that he went through and they're doing
the same kind of shots of what he saw
from navarro but now on the different
side of things i like the moment when he
decides to have this man killed the
priest walks away from him and again
it's that character of marty we know
it's hard for him to just kill people
especially now knowing he's an innocent
man however where the inconsistency lies
with stuff like this in ozark is that
this episode he's having these feelings
about killing innocent man especially in
the season when he'll learn that he was
innocent that just scoffs off them
getting actually their therapist killed
i still not over how quickly that was
resolved where the birds didn't feel
anything about her dying which was just
bizarre and they kind of choose areas
for them to actually care and some they
just kind of don't even address so there
is an inconsistency in the show in that
department but i like the conversation
the priest has marty in this episode
about unconditional love and conditional
love and really showing you too how like
marty is his character where it is very
conditional for marty with a lot of
things and love in general in his life
which can be his tragic flaw what i
didn't like was the stuff with ruth in
this episode was good and again the roof
stuff's my favorite in this season but
it felt like a giant u-haul commercial
about a quarter of this episode we're
just constantly seeing u-haul fit into
the frame the logo which can get a
little annoying when it's too much i get
you got to pay the bills but don't
overkill it i like we saw ben's death
actually where usually i wouldn't like
that they show the sabine episode i
think that it was good to see he forgave
wendy i think that showed that oh yeah
that is confirming how we know ben is
that good of a guy that he would do that
and understand what wendy did even
though i don't i hate when these guts
still but i love the ruth versus wendy
stuff going on it's always great when
they have little showdowns here and
there and even wendy trying to tip off
on the shaw deal ruth won that battle in
this episode outplayed her but i wasn't
crazy about some of the mel scenes in
these first couple episodes i think just
kind of boring and what's tough about
the character of mel is that i wish they
made him more interesting and more time
to his character instead of just showing
him put clues together where ozark at
its best which was in season one which
they haven't done since was having the
fbi agent who they killed off too soon
be so interesting that he was this
character with a lot of flaws and even
not having flaws just we knew him well
and that's what was so great about ozark
season one was everyone had their time
to shine even charlotte and jonah had
time where again unfortunately they
really dropped their character stories
too where i was more interested when
jonah was skinning deer than having him
really do not much of anything and don't
get me started on charlotte who i think
is a really good actress and they could
do more with her i'm so interested to
know how are these kids being affected
by their parents and they dropped that
out a lot too in these past couple
seasons but that's one of my criticisms
too as a show as a whole but i don't
want to go too into that because again
i'm trying to focus on this second half
of season four but i'm giving this
episode 9.1 again i really really
enjoyed it the whole scheme of ozark i
really enjoyed these first three
episodes i thought they were actually
excellent and so entertaining and
exciting now where it started dip for me
a bit was episode 11 titled pound of
flesh and still kicking now what's
interesting is directed by laura linney
wendy bird herself and written by ning
zao now i love seeing the og characters
coming back right like rachel and we
even got to see tuck which was pretty
cool and that was strange though with
the writing because rachel got her
moment with marty and yelling at him for
not taking care of tuck like he promised
and that's it that wasn't ever brought
up again so that was weird now what
makes me hate wendy even more scenes
like her telling rachel everything about
ruth in that moment the casino you get
why wendy does what she does but it's
all out of selfishness constantly and
it's so frustrating because it's not
always about her protecting your
children a lot of times it is but
there's that selfishness of wanting this
power running you know the ozarks greed
that just makes her so unlikable and
that's why i thought it was interesting
too i just brought up about marty this
episode's really feeling guilt for
killing an innocent man but he even
mentions the shrink in this episode but
again it wasn't really addressed at the
time like why was that so thrown over on
him that he didn't really seem like he
was affected by it i thought the best
moment in this episode was marty having
the moment to talk to charlotte about
what he felt about wendy and that she
was driving them off a cliff and that
she trusted camille and he didn't and
the problems he had with her choice of
killing ben i thought that stuff was
really good and stuff i think a lot of
the audience members can agree with and
i like that they had their grandpa
getting closer here so things were
starting to get really intense and
having ruth and rachel trying to get the
casino so all these pieces again working
really well and we see marty hit his
breaking point because then when he
makes a choice again without telling
marty which they both do to each other
but this one about having camilla take
over the cartel and he beats up a guy in
traffic now at the time when i watch
this episode i really like that ending
scene but as i look back i don't think
it worked as well like i don't a lot of
this i don't think had great payoff into
character changing choices i i don't
think at the end of the day there was
enough of a consistency like okay
marty's at his breaking point did we get
that full discovered by the end of this
show and it's finale i don't think so
which i'll get again i'm saving a lot of
this for the finale because i have a lot
of thoughts about it but it was a solid
episode and a good directing episode by
laura laney i was impressed with it so
i'm excited to see her do more of that
so i'm giving this one an 8.6 but not as
good as the first couple now an episode
i really did like was episode 12 trouble
the water again directed by amanda
marsalis who's actually killing it here
directing and written by paul cosby and
martin zimmerman and even moments that i
like about the directing little things
that mean so much like the kids having
to bail their parents out of jail now
but them sitting in the back seat of the
minivan and the kids driving they have
to be the adults in this family where we
know the birds can act like children
most of the time now where you start
getting worried about ruth was things
are starting to come up roses for her
she's lost so much but we see she's
getting her record now clean and you see
she's planning to build this pool in
this house and you're like okay that
worries your show because when things
start going good death is looming and we
actually eventually get them the finale
which sucks because i was trying to look
at it as like i hope they're actually
setting up if they're gonna do a
spin-off for ozark because it's such a
successful show critically and also with
viewership that the clear route would be
a story with ruth ruth is the star of
the show now and you're wrapping up the
bird story and you're setting up more
for ruth why not do another ruth show so
that's why i was so shocked they killed
ruth and that you can't even leave a
door open to do a ruth prequel like you
do it like a better call solid say
because if you go back to ruth's days
when she was first in the ozarks as a
child you can't have julie garner play
her when she's 12 or 11 whatever just
doesn't work so it's bizarre to me that
they killed ruth because i thought there
was so much good set up here to actually
have her do her own story in the future
for another spin-off and i don't know i
just think that's strange but i like
with this that you know she's doing this
story of like ending the langmore curse
right and trying to live a life that's
you know away from all this of all this
stuff she's lost again as always you're
just rooting for ruth and what makes me
roll my eyes at the wendy character so
much is how she's so more concerned
about her own you know election and
voting machine morals than killing her
own brother that's the stuff that just
makes me roll my eyes with that
character but this sets up now mel
putting the pieces together what the
birds are up to and now the grandpa
wants custody of the kids and this is
where this story is gonna lean into that
storyline now towards the end of the
show and i love the end of this episode
because when the grandpa wins the kids
in this custody battle you know
charlotte gets to say to wendy basically
what marty said to her about wendy and
how selfish wendy can be and wendy
played by laura lenny laura lindy my
favorite performance of hers was in this
episode of the whole show because i love
when she's pleading to her father and
she taps into the scared child she was
around her father right that happens
here when she's pleading to him for
don't take my kids this is the thing she
wants more than anything is her children
right and that's why i love her
performance when she bangs her head
against the wall i thought that was
probably the best moment of the season
for sure and my favorite moment with
laura lenny's acting and shout out to
just directing her by amanda marsalis
from that end scene in the courtroom to
laura lenny banging her head i thought
that was really well done so that was on
my favorite episodes of the season i'm
giving it a 9.2 now when we go to the
penultimate episode mud this is where
things start to take a dip for me and
doesn't go up from there this is where i
thought part two was some of the best of
ozarks since season one and then it just
dipped out and i'm gonna give my reasons
why so this was directed by amanda
marsalis again written by miki johnson
so it opens you know the storm's coming
right and wendy wants to check in the
behavioral center after everything i
just went down but the birds need still
to launder the money through the casino
ruth now has and i like this moment when
he says to her father i am not as nearly
devout and i will kill you before i let
you take my kids and i love also moment
with wendy when rachel says to wendy you
have no human decency or a sense of
humor and wendy's like i have a sense of
humor to herself she says after but it's
so true about what rachel said and i
like the moment priest says the wendy
killed the man or joined the church she
connects the dots her joined the church
basically the church being the
behavioral health center and she's like
you're gonna let me in this hospital i'm
gonna kill my father but the plan
backfires with camille because navarro
tells camille that he didn't kill javi
so things start to go haywire here where
it started getting not as good the show
for me was this scene with ruth and her
talking to the grandpa you know we know
it's necessary to set up stuff that
happens a finale between them but it
felt just like a bad scene it felt off
contrived forced in with them talking
and they have this point in the
penultimate episode starting to feel
like you're interested but you're like
shouldn't more be happening now with
these characters we're in the final to
last episode of the whole show and
you're ending it on a cliffhanger
involving rachel right again this is
what happens a finale but again you feel
like why why this character why her
shooting nelson who's chasing after ruth
and her to keep the laundry going and
have that be that big like shocking
moment with the storm i just don't think
it landed that well and then it kind of
gets resolved right away at the top of
the finale when marty talks to ruth and
that nelson's at the bottom of the pool
but at the end of the day it really
wasn't much of the weight if you imagine
this show ozarks gonna have in their pen
ultimate episode for the whole show like
that's it like that was just one of
those like uh i don't know it was
building suspense like it always does
really well but at that point i think he
wanted to spend time maybe with the
birds more or somebody else because it
was a lot of rachel so that was strange
to me so that episode for me was an 8.4
i just don't think it was as good it
started worrying me like okay now i'm
getting the feelings how are they gonna
wrap all these stories satisfying way
that's gonna make people happy in one
episode well my worries become true
because then we go to the finale a hard
way to go which to me is one of the
worst episodes of ozark ever and of the
season i don't know if you feel the same
way but i want to say how i feel this
was directed by jason bateman who
usually directs the best episodes and
written by chris mundy so you see
navarro's killed right which is part of
the plan and the best moment i think the
finale was the moment with ruth and the
grandpa where she's like i'll shoot you
in your head that one if you don't have
the kids go back right and we see wendy
finally says to the kids that the
bending is her fault not ruth's because
ruth finally had a nice moment with
wendy in the hospital right saying that
she thinks ben thing was her fault all
this stuff going great nice whatever but
where this stuff goes haywire is you
know everything's coming up roses now
for the birds we know everything's happy
for ruth now she's thinking of her
family the pool's there she has a nice
moment with three and then you're like
okay but is it gonna end on a happy note
well things go crazy when sean now
basically just spills the beans to
camilla and this is where i get annoyed
because okay this is where stuff goes
crazy you're all excited your blood's
pumping like ozark usually makes it but
marty says to wendy can we bear it
meaning letting ruth die here now they
were put against the wall because okay
are you gonna let your kids now be at
risk by trying to protect ruth clearly
wendy's not gonna do that so that makes
sense but for me marty would not just
let ruth go that easily at this moment i
don't care that his kids were at risk if
he did anything else he would have tried
something you need to show me something
of him trying they talked through with
it a little bit and of course wendy
messed things up by being cocky of
course and telling schaefer that he can
screw off even though they ended up
meeting him at the end of the day so
again just make sure your eyes at wendy
and having ruth then killed by camilla
here it was just like oh like you're
killing the best character yes i know
it's the end of the show but again i i
think
they're gonna want to make more ozark
stuff because of how successful it is
and how popular is how netflix needs
their own original content because
they're struggling as a company right
now you're seeing how many subscribers
losing and you're going to get rid of
the best character on the show which you
could do a potential spin-off on i don't
think people are going to want to watch
a jonah or charlotte spin-off which is
just bizarre to me and why this is all
bizarre to me is because ruth dying
isn't satisfying that core relationship
the show to me like you look at mad men
right where you had peggy and don
draper's relationship you have walter
white and jesse pinker's relationship we
know that that core relationship is
marty and ruth that's what people are
connecting to and to have it that well
she dies and marty didn't really do
anything to protect her
that's not satisfying that is not how
you want to end this show and that's
where i have a head scratch so at that
point him letting ruth die makes me want
the birds to die here now i'm like screw
them so i'm actually rooting for mel
when he comes through here with the
ashes of ben and then you have jonah who
predictably was going to come with a
shotgun you know it was coming at that
moment so that kind of made me roll my
eyes fade to black with him definitely
shooting mel there's a small chance
maybe he turned and shot you know wendy
because he loved ben so much and maybe
he thought they deserved it the parents
but i don't think so i think he clearly
killed mel but i feel like they went for
the stylistic choice without feeling the
weight of the emotions in that moment
where i was like oh let's make it like
the bonnie and clyde thing in the cool
you know the bad people went at the end
and you thought they're gonna get caught
i don't care about that really you know
i think that's just a stylistic choice
to see something that they thought would
be a crowd-pleasing moment for me i want
to feel something i want to feel closure
in that sense and having ruth die and
not have that address more with marty
and that decision to you know not
protect protector made me feel like
maybe we could have had one more season
of this maybe this ended too early and
that we had such good episodes here in
the season basically up to the final two
for me so i'm giving this one a 6.9 i
thought that again i'm gonna give a
points up for excitement levels and
suspense it built with camilla there at
the end but i just don't think it was a
good finale and a good story and feeling
satisfied about what's been set up in
this show in particular with ruth and
that it just felt like you wanted
something more there so it was like oh
let's not even talk about the minivan
flipping right because you started the
season showing us that didn't mean
anything in the day no like they got out
unscathed just a little tease that's the
stuff that makes ozark not at that level
of like a breaking bad of sopranos it's
gonna stay there as it was a good show
very consistently good never really bad
really exciting stuff like for me my
thoughts on ozark as a whole is like you
know i love season one i think it was
the best season because it had more
weight to every single character and
then they killed a lot of characters too
early that's why i had a lot of problems
with season two and season three i do
think season four was the second best
season and it was really focused well on
ruth now and that's what made it so good
but it dropped the ball at the end so
that's how i feel let me know your
thoughts on ozark season four part two
let me know your thoughts on the show as
a whole where you think they can go from
here will they make a spin off will they
not i'd love to hear your thoughts on
that please follow me at steve barley
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
for more of me and please make sure to
subscribe it helps me in so many ways
you have no idea i really want to be
able to do this full time one day so it
will only help me able to do more videos
for you guys and i'll see you next time